大家好,我是Yoni
嗯,那很开心呢
今天又以这样直播的形式跟大家见面了
那今天呢,咱们是接上一次
又邀请到了海外机构
DCP的联合丧使人郎一鸣老师
那一鸣老师呢,本身也是升更量化快20年了
那他们机构的管理规模本身也已经超了12亿美金
那一鸣老师呢,以前呢,是在骑士资本
此前呢,也受邀在国内一些高校做过讲座
那今天呢,是因为上一次
我要请一鸣老师做了这个
基于机器学习构建量化交易模型全流程拆解
这样的一个主题分享之后
那有很多小伙伴呢,其实都在私心问我相关线下课程的问题
所以呢,今天又是特地邀请到了鸣鸣老师
来专门为小伙伴们进行关于这个线下课程的一个课前答疑
那接下来呢,我就先把时间先交到给鸣老师
鸣老师
OK
哎,那个,大家好啊,王一鸣
嗯,Yoni刚才也讲了,因为之前是做过一次那个
关于这个机器学习构建量化模型的这个
流程的拆解的主题分享啊,然后
可能有很多小伙伴有很多问题啊
因为就是因为我们
下个月正好是
六月份是在国内有那个相关的课程
所以大家如果大伙有什么针对课程
有问题的话可以直接上麦哈
或者是这个在那个
聊天的那个
那边直接把问题
那个打出来也可以哈
然后我们继续好
嗯
是这样的
就是关于整个的这个
呃
就是机器学习的这个框架呢,然后
呃,是这样的
我想分几个内容先给大家再讲一下哈
讲完之后呢,然后针对我们线下课程的核心的价值和内
和那个相关的内容
然后再深入的再讲一下
对,然后这边分几个部分哈
那第一呢,就是说我们整个量化
策略的一个大的一个框架哈
另外呢,就是说
因为涉及到不同的这个
呃,量化策略的设计
对,所以呢,每一种量化策略呢
它的第一
就是第一性原理是什么哈
第二呢,就是说
嗯,第三呢,就是说
基于这个整个
Motion Learning的这个
就是机器学习的技术路径的
全链路的一个规划
对,然后第四呢
是针对国内的这个
商品期货
还有股票的ETF
还有像
Crypto加密货币的
一个实证的一个研究哈
最后是这个相关课程的内容
对,然后我们先看一下
因为呃,我也
判了很多国内的这个
呃,讲量化的这个相关的课程
对,就是基本上可能是大家在
因子方面或者在这个
付现延报方面的比较多
但是其实整个的
嗯,量化的框架
其实需要大家有一个
全局的一个视角哈
就不仅仅
是在某一两个环节
对,然后所以说
我们先把这个大概的这个
量化的框架先了解一下
那大家肯定在视面上
听到很多像
什么趋势啊,套利啊,中性啊
什么轮动啊,什么指增啊
像这类的策略哈
其实我爱护
都是这种
嗯,像是
嗯,如据啊
或是截面
两大类的这个
策略组成的哈
那截面的其实
是比这个时序要多一个维度哈
因为时序比如说我们对
单一品种进行这个研究
肯定是基于它是
是相关的嘛
对,那么截面呢
可能会是在这个
单一品种的这个
时序特征的基础上
然后进行了相关的这种
排序或者叫比较哈
那产生了一些
比如说
某种风
某那个
怎样的这种风格
然后来赚取这种风格的钱啊
那举此同时呢
整个量化的时候
从最早的这种
线性的规则类
慢慢的转为这种
比如特征啊
多因子的这种框架
那当下呢
很多的这种
海外啊
以及国内的机构也都慢慢的
准乡了这个
机器学习的这种
技术路
这是这种技术路径哈
因为
嗯,坦率讲
嗯
嗯,其实如果是基于
最早的这种
呃,这一篇
就是资本资产定价模型来讲的话
其实
呃
这个传统的金融理论
其实缺乏了
呃,特征之间
或者叫做因子之间的这种
C线性结构的这种研究哈
那么传统的金融框架
基本上都是孤立的哈
比如说对单一特征或者叫做
对单一因子进行显应
但是缺乏了这个
因子和因子
或者叫特征和特征之间的这种
C线性关系的研究
那当下其实机器学习就是很好了
很好地补充了
团统金融理论的
这么一个缺失的这个榜块
呃,那针对不同的策略呢
其实我们要清楚
我们相关要赚到
市场上怎样的钱哈
对
那这五个策略呢
其实就是比较常见的哈
也相对比较主流
那第一呢
比如说是
像这种居士型策略
那我们知道其实它是在赚这个
相关的钱哈
那简单的来讲的话
其实也就是说赚这个市场惯性的这个钱
比如说的上涨的话
可能是不是一直在上涨
那下跌的话呢
会不会一直下跌哈
对
那正常的这种金融标的呢
其实都是有很强的这种自相关性
那所以呢
我们在做趋势策略的时候
其实也很容易能拿到这部分的这个利润哈
但是呢
这个大家可以看到第二个这种策略
比如说均值回归
那均值回归呢
其实就是和这个趋势策略相互互补
因为有趋势就要有回归
那比如说我们在某一个标的
长到一定价格的时候
他可能会回归到某一个护血上的
一个负值
对
然后那如果这个他可能是在频繁的
这个负值之间来宽查哈
那如果这样的话呢
那其实我们可以在某种情况下
做相应的这种很均值回归的这种策略
那也就是说我们的这个价格和价值
他其实是在不断的这种偏离修复
在这种循环
对
但是其实最难的是什么
最难的其实就是我们如何把这个
趋势和震荡风海
那其实这个
因为现在有的这种模型
可能都会存在相应的这种叫
我们叫边界效应
也就是说对当前的状态其实很难判断
可能有的小伙伴会问
那那比如说我们看这个配线图
那他是上涨还是下跌
那其实我们用这个眼睛一看
其实是就能判清的
那为什么这个模型判断
当前的状态会很难
那其实是这个样子
因为我们人眼看到
其实这个也不是他当前的状态
因为他其实你看到的已经是发生过的
也就说我们用现有的所有的这种
除了用这种引波来表达特
来表达这个市场特征之外
其实我们所有的数据也都是质后的
那我们再来看这个节面策略
那节面策略其实是在时序的基础上
那加了一个相对的一个比较或者是排序
更多的使用在这种
我们比如说对这个股票市场
使用的是最多的
那当然说时序和节面会很好的这种结合
那因此其实我们的课程也都是先从时序来开始讲
然后最后以这个比如说进阶课案
然后节面可最后再讲到配置
那所以大家可以看到
那我们对时序策略了解之后
其实对节面再展开相关的研究
其实就会容易很多
那除了这个趋势、均资回归、节面
那还有相应的这个套利的这个策略
那套利的策略我记得之前也做过一期
专门做过一期是套利
是用趋势的方式做套利
就是完全不同的这种框架
那其实套利策略基本上和
上面提到的这个第二个均资回归的这个策略
其实有一点点类似
那只是单纯的均资回归
可能是在某一个标的上来做
那套利其实我们会找到
比如说一对这个标的
或者是更多的这种套利的标的
来统一进行这种计算
那所以我们要知道这个套利
其实这个
大家也都知道套利的这个策略
其实相关的风险还是偏低的
因为它基本上用现有的这种方式
比如说像是这种传统的这种统计的方法来做的话
其实这个风险度还是相当可控的
那当然说也可以用我之前讲到的这个
不一样的这个套利策略来做
相当于是我们套利的策略
其实就完全变成了这个居势性策略
那是另外的一种自卑方式
那最后其实就是和波动率策略相关的
基本上可能这部分策略
更多的是在松显对空以及做这个期权套利
或者是期权相关的这个方面上
对 那更多的其实
我们看到更多的其实还是这个
能趋势策略以及这个节面策略
那其他的比如说像军阻回归套利
这个都是类似的
那波动率策略更多的
可能是给我们节面或者是趋势策略
做这个松显对冲用的
但是我们要清楚
每种策略其实转的是不同的
这点是很关键的
然后因为提到机器学习的话
其实它的既复入境还是这个满长的
对 它不太像其他的比如说
规则类的一些方法
相对比较简单单纯
那机器学习
因为它是完全是复学逻辑
然后找到特征和特征之间的
这种非线性关系
所以我们希望在数据处理的
或者叫做数据分析
数据处理的这个环节
其实就可以让数据变得更具有统计意义
那所以我们的课程
也是从这个全链路规划来出发
那也是希望大家能够
从平时零零散散的这些片面的知识
能够把所有的这个全占的技术能够串起来
那所以我们课程也是针对这个整体来统筹
然后分布来实施的这么一个方式
然后也是希望打破这个像IT数学
以及金融的这种学科的壁垒
那毕竟基于这个机器学习的这个量化模型的设计
其实是需要跨学科的这种能力
那所以我们这边给大家看到的全链路规划
其实也就是说我们课程上会详细讲到的一些环节
那当然说这里边也有很多我们没有写出来的内容
那这个设定一轴的这个重采样和时间轴的对比
其实这个是我对习惯性要讲的这个内容
因为我们要知道
因为我们后续是要用机器学习来训练模型的
所以前期的这个数据处理
我们希望它可以共具有统计特性一些
那右边的这个图其实就是我们传统意义上的这个时间维度的
这个一阶差分的这个概率分布
大家可以看到那个虚线的部分是正台的
那红色的部分是一阶差分之后的概率分布
大家可以看到其实他们的这个峰值其实还是蛮高的
就是峰值我在课程上会证明给大家看
那这个峰值其实变相就代表的是我们的这个
市场震荡的这个评词
那也就说你在尾部赚到的钱
其实基本上会在这个这个峰值的这个部分会亏掉
那也就说比如说你在一个长的一个上涨
或者是下跌的这个趋势中赚到的钱
那比如说我们在进入震荡的时候
其实你会发现比如说你刚做多的时候
那其实你是房间可能又下来了
那下来之后你做空之后
然后这个行情又上涨
就经常会有这种情况的来回被来回被洗
对所以我们知道一看到这个图的话
其实我们就很清楚
那假设在这种不具有统计意义的这种分布上的来进行
策略设定的话其实是很难的
对然后基本上也赚不到太多的这个钱
因为尾部赚到的钱其实都会在这个部分来亏掉
那同样的其实我们建议大家还是进行这种
对市场的这个数据进行重采样
然后变成我们自定义的这个维度的这个筹法
那但是说这个是给大家举了一个简单的一个例子
这个是用成交额来做的
那大家可以看到这个在配线也就是82的数量
相差不多的情况下
就相似的情况下
其实我们的这个概率分布会更接近于正态
其实是这个我们在调整完重采样之后是附加的这个价值
对其实我们的核心是要满足我们每一个BAR内部的这个信息密度更均匀
也就是说为我们后门积极学习的这个训练的这个BaseLine
然后做了很好的这个数据处理的准备
那其实这个也是我们在无论是在做节面
还是在做实际的时候
无论是在做节面还是在做实际的时候
策略的设计的时候的第一步
那如果是我们采用这种有监督的这个极其学习的基础路线的话
那其实我们都避不开
我们要对市场的数据进行标注
那这里边我们是用这个概率巨类的方式来做这个数据数学层面上的一个标注
因为传统的标注
比如说用这个未来的收益啊
或者是你上涨就标一下跌就不要负一或者标零的话
那其实这种方式是不具有统计意义
不是不太具有统计意义的
因为我们要知道
因为我们交易的时候
其实是如果我们做假设我们做趋势性策略的设计的话
那我们希望那他上涨的这个过程中的这个有一些小的回调
其实是对我们没有产生什么影响的
希望我们的这个持仓是连续的
那所以一句更这个落地的这种交易相结合的话
那其实我希望是进行这种确实性标签的这种标注
那这个也是就是进入到后面的这个有监督的这个模型训练的一个
这个其实就是我们的外哈
也就是说我们的这个标签
对那在标签做完之后呢
当然说我们还有相应的这个特征工程
这里边呢展示了大家其实看到的就是我们
不跌的一些的这个特征哈
大家可以看到这个
呃 比如说是变相进行的这个变相进行的这个标准化
之后的这个特征的矩阵
那这个我们会用这个
这个其实就是我们的x哈
那我们会用这个特征去学习到那个标签哈
呃 在呃 当然说这个之前也做过一些对比哈
那右面的这个其实就是呃
我们在对时间轴
就没有进行的布局从采样的
呃布局进行这个模型训练之后
就是所有的步骤都一致的情况下
那其实我们看到它的这个呃
手艺啊
然后最大回彻
塔马
包括我们的
这个回彻面积
其实都要比这个
从采样之后的这个自定一轴的这个要弱很多
哈
当然说我们呃
其实训练的方式也完全也是相同的
包括用降维的方式也都是相同的
那左边大家可以看到
那我们在做单一模型训练完之后呢
然后我们会进行相应的这种组合哈
那组合之后的这个手艺还是蛮可观的
对那后面有几个图哈
那这个其实是针对这个商品期货哈
因为国内的商品期货呃是更接近于海外哈
那我们也可以做多
也可以做空啊
那大家看到这是差不多25个月的数据吧
对训练完之后做完的模型组合
差不多是呃收益总的收益是这个67.81
哈
然后这个这个最大回测是5.78卡马是在无以上哈
然后DA是我们自己的这个指标
就这个课上会给大家代码
也就是说我们这个橘色的这个回彻面积哈
其实这个回彻面积还是蛮关键
因为它代表的其实就是我们交易者
或者是你的资方的一个心理阴影的面积哈
对那这个回彻面积越小
其实代表我们的这个回补期会更快哈
对那个这是RB的这个数据
因为国内的这个RB是多空都可以做哈
不同样的我们对这个国内的互生300的ETF
也进行了模型的训练哈
那这个其实就是呃
呃这个收益是107
最大回测是15.69卡马是5.49
这个回彻面积会更小一点哈
这是进行了15个月的这个测试
其实涵盖了这个从15年前年到到这个
今年的这个3月底哈
大家可以看到这基本上这个该吃的这个趋势
其实都不知道
然后该亏损的部分的其实都是没有持仓的
因为国内的这个呃ETF其实是我们没有办法做空哈
所以我们只能是单边做多的这么一种方式
另外呢还有对这个ETA上哈
Crypto的这个加密货币的这个
做了一个相应的这个模型的呃训练
这个收益是81
最大回测15卡马也是在5以上哈
回测面积是86.53
因为呃Crypto特别是ETH
像BGC这类的呃Crypto的屏种的话
它因为它的这个呃波动还是蛮大
对所以呢在做这个
像单一呃标的的时候呢
我们其实还是建议呃
大家可以把很多的这个标的来同时来做哈
要同时做很多标的的话
其实能够相对相对应的能对通掉相应的这个
嗯
之间的这个风险哈
然后前面呢是简单的给大家过了一下哈
因为很多的内容是涉及到这个
嗯线下课就是线下课的这个里的内容呢
因为在这个公开的这个主题分享的时候
可能我就不太方便来讲了哈
因为我们要对这个
之前这个上过线下课的小伙伴要负责哈
对
那么我再讲一下这个相应的其实课里的
这个核心的意义哈
那第一呢
其实我们希望是大家能够有这种全站的能力哈
那也就是说从一开始的这个数据处理
到这个从太阳的做定律轴
然后标签啊特征降维训练回测
评估组和推理实盘等等
那其实我们希望是大家能够掌握整个的全流程
因为坦率讲这个嗯量化率行业
因为离钱太近了哈
所以这个有很多时候
比如说大家零零散散看到一些内容
可能有的时候会很难串起来啊
对
那所以呢这个第一呢
我们觉得是能够把全站的这种方式
能够和大家来公开
那其实对于大家来讲的话呢
其实就是完全是非常干的干货哈
第二呢是这个让大家能够从
这个整个的帕特曼里面能
你会到更多的是作为方式嘛
因为有的时候我们觉得
技术可能不是最重要的
因为有现在有这个
比如说有AI啊
然后大家可以让这个大圆模型来
辅助我们来写一些代码什么的
但是其实你发现
如果你没有好的这个思路
或者叫你没有整整个统筹的一个
呃认知的话
那其实你用AI它给到的结果
也都是比较一般的
对所以说最重要的还是还是希望
大家能够从课程当中
能够学到本多的这个作为方式
对以及处理技术问题的一些个
毕竭的方法和想法
那那第三呢
其实是让大家能够在量化的过程中
能够打破一些壁垒
因为我们更多的是讲的是数学逻辑
其实因为参加过课程的小伙伴
可能会比较清楚
就是我们基本上和金融相关的
内容很少
就基本上是没有完全是数学逻辑
因为我们清楚这个很多
在模型训练的时候
因为模型它对你是哪个行业
它是不清楚的
那它完全是这种不学逻辑
所以所以我们从这个
每一个环节其实都是会用数学的方式
来进行相应的这个处理
对那其实大家也能够体会到
因为我们机器学习
其实不仅仅是模型训练的
那一个环节用这个方式
那其实我们在很多环节
也都有会把一些有监督
或者是无监督的这种
这个机器学学系的方法
运到我们其实一些各个环节当中
那最后的其实也是希望
大家能够通过课程
能够能够自主的训练模型
其实我们团败了
基本上全市场所有的这个标地
那希望大家能够
就是那无论是做国内的标地
还是海外的这个标地
无论是多空
同时做还是这个只能够做多
那其实都可以用我们的这个
还是用我们的这个生产线的
计工家来实现
那其实这个就是我们的课程
主要的这个价值
另外就是这两页
其实就是我们课程的大纲
因为之前有很多小伙伴
其实我都会比较清楚
他们看到这个大纲之后
可能就会想自己想办法去复线
其实我倒是建议大家
其实如果是有能力复线的话
也可以复线
那但是其实这里面
面临很多的这种逆节的问题
因为我们还是建议大家
能够参加我们的这个线下课
就算说我们不是专业讲课的
我们也不做国内的这个市场
其实这个反而会更愿意讲一些端获
因为我们和大家没有这个
直接的这个程度
那我帮大家把这个课程的这个内容
换一下
待会大家如果有问题的话
直接就可以上班
或者是把文字打出来也可以
那第一呢
我们既然是要讲这个机器学习
在整个的这个量化模型的这个全流程中的应用
那其实我们的机器学习
也是作为我们的一个基础
比如说我们哪类的模型是能够用的
那哪类的模型是我们没有办法使用的
另外呢
就是说一些思维方式
我觉得这是最关键的
那其实这个也是机器学习讲的这个内容
那第二个部分
其实就是数据的这个数据
获取以及分析
因为很多时候我们在做这个
这个模型之前
其实很少会对数据进行相应的
这种分析和数据
可能拿到数据直接就打标钱
可能直接就就进行这个模型训练的
那其实这个
然后重点都在模型调谈上
那其实是这样的
其实我们的数据处理能力
其实是整个机器学习的这个
能够得到很好结果的一个天花板
也就是说你出你数据处理能力的好
那其实你的这个
后续训练出来的结果也会很好
也就是说你前期可能没有这些动作的话
你后边大概率的这个模型
也是没有办法用的好
对另外呢
也是我们的这个第三个环节
其实就是我们
对试探的这个数据进行的重采样
刚才也给大家看到
因为采样方式其实很多
就是多种多样
但是说重点是方法论
对不是说是我们要接近于政态等等
那其实我们要知道每一个环节
背后的这个核心的逻辑
大家看到它接近于政态程度
那都是表象
那这个重点是它背后的这个逻辑
那第四项其实就是我们要对这个
数据进行相应的这个标筑
因为我们后面是做有监督的这个模型训练
所以要对这个数据进行相应的标筑
还能不同的标筑方法
那其实这个也会影响到我们这个模型的训练
那其实大家可以看到
其实我们每一个环节和环节之间都是相通的
然后互相互之间它是有结统意义
并不是说独立的
比如说我做完A
就做B算B就做C
其实我们是有关联的
那也就是说比如说我们在下
就是比如说我们在后面的几步
然后比如说它在对前边
就是前边的一些参数的调整
其实对我们后面的这个步骤
其实是有直接的关联的
这一点是很重要
对 这一点也是希望能够在课程上
让大家能够体会到
也就说除了这种全局的这种视角以外
希望大家能够更深刻的理解
就是每个环节之间的这种闲空逻辑
然后像第五个环节特征
然后比如说互聚降维
然后其实这两个是可以是结合在一起
那目的是把我们的大量的这个
比如说有噪音
或者是有这种贡献性问题的这个特征
能够把维度能够降下来
降维我们也会讲线性和非线性
当然说线性的里面会有很多的这个实盘
套作的时候的困惨
那我们如何规避
我们也会都会非常详细的讲
那后面就是说涉及到这个模型训练
以及这个模型的专用性和通用性的这个问题
那最后涉及到这个模型的组合
以及这个模型的规理和实盘的交易
大家可能会误认为
比如说我模型训练完之后
可能就代表着我大部分99的工作已经做完了
那其实是不是这样的
因为模型训练之后
可能仍仅完成了一半的工作
那更多的挑战其实都会在模型的组合
以及在这个推理和实盘的交易中
那这里边会
大家会遇到很多各种各样的这个问题
那我们在课程上也会详细的
带着大家把这个流程跑通
所以大家可以看到那其实是我们前边
就是这个图就是会讲的比较清楚
其实大家可以体会到
那其实我们是在讲一个全链路的一个规划
对
然后目的是让大家有这种铜头的视角
以及会清楚各个环节之间的这种鞋头的逻辑
对
它并不是说是独立的
这个是最关键的
对
那也希望的是我们6月份的先下课程
能够给大家带来一个不一样的感受
对
那看看这个我的这个简单的介绍就到这里
看看大家有没有关于课程想问的一些问题
打在那个聊天的内里的也可以
或者是直接连麦都可以
OK
谢谢宁美老师的讲解
那咱们今天的小伙伴
就是因为我想大概今天来参加的小伙伴
都是之前有跟我这边简单的
有了解过这个咱们的一个课程大纲的
因为我不知道大家可能还会有一些细节性的问题
所以说呢
今天就正好是让疫苗师这边专门抽出时间来
给大家做这样的一个客签答疑
对
所以说大家如果有什么问题
因为之前疫苗师也做过好几次这个
就是公开课了
那大家可能也都有看过
所以说呢
就大家可以有啥问题
也都可以上麦来直接提问
因为机会比较难得
然后因为疫苗师
他们本身机构管理规模也还是挺大的
对
所以这个我觉得机会确实比较难得
所以说看大家问题就可以提问
好吗
对
一鸣老师
我想问两个问题
就是一个是关于那个自定义轴的
一个是关于这个标签的
然后我在那个消息框里发了一个PDF
那个是我初步浮现了一下
然后做了一些实验
然后我第一个问题是关于自定义轴的
就是我发现
就是自定义轴
我就不打开了
然后这个文件
因为我要展示这个共享屏幕
然后我就不打开了
然后你直接问就可以了
行
就是第一个问题是关于自定义轴
就是我发现它这个
就是统计意义上这个风度
还有这个就是在
就是军职零附近的
E Sigma的这个位置上的这个比例
然后还有就是这个Bar的数量
就是往往不能见得
就是尤其是我想要一个比较大的
一个Bar的数量的话
它往往就是在中间
就是正负0.5 Sigma那个位置上的那个
Bar的比例会这个变高
所以这块怎么去平衡这个Bar的数量
以及中间的这个风度
而且我在很多ETF上
会发现一些肥尾的现象
然后是不是对于这种趋势性的策略
肥尾是可以允许的
也就是这个风度
克尔就是传统意义上的这个
风度大一些其实无所谓
只要把中间的这个E Sigma位置里面的这个
就是Bar的比例给它降下来就可以了
这个是那个第一个问题
就是关于自定义轴
然后第二个问题是关于那个标签
就是非监督去生成标签的这么一个问题
也是做了一些实验
也是基于一些美股的一些这个ETF
然后我的问题是
就是视频里说
就是最好标签的这个军职
要驱逐0.5后面比较好训练
这个我在ETF上会发现
我做出来的标签大概在0.7附近
就是那个军职在0.7附近
因为它肯定是有一个那个往上走的
一个趋势嘛
所以就是我需要在这个标签生成的阶段
就给它压到0.5合适呢
还是说我在那个训练的阶段
用一些这个后采样的方法
去把这个标签压到0.5附近会比较好呢
就是一个是我我通过
比如说调整HMM的这个
银马可夫的这个
里面的各种参数
然后来压到0.5
还是这个做后处比较好
因为这个数据本身
它就有一定的这个趋势性
所以就是在前面
在前面做这个Label balance
还是在后边做
就是在模型训练的时候做比较好
就是我的这两个问题
OK 因为涉及到了很多的这个
我们课程上是要讲的内容哈
然后我只能是
就是稍微大概的回答你
一大哈
然后也还是建议你来
参加那个我们线下的课
第一个就是标签的
那个第一个是这个
重采样轴的那个问题
其实是这样的
因为我不知道你的那个方式
因为比如说我大概率能猜到
你是比如说用AI辅助写的这个代码
什么的
因为其实我们还是保持着这种
传统的这种
我们自己来写代码的这种方式
就是说是我们比如说
如果我们记住AI的话
可能会是在一些这个
比如说把我们的代码减量的方式上
会用到这个AI
但是主要核心的这个内容
其实还是我们自己来写
这个是比较关键的
所以说我是觉得
可能做这边一轴的那个方式
其实和我们要讲的方式
可能还有很大的这个区别
对那这是第一
第二就是你刚才提到的这个风度
包括这个
这个就是导节的这个
顾量的方式
其实坦率讲这个
因为我不能多说
希望你能理解
因为涉及到这个很多课程上的一些
细节
因为要对得起这个
之前上过课的这些个小伙伴
对那这个
那这是关于自定义轴
另外就是说
你刚才提到的这个
这个标签
那标签呢
其实这个方法有很多
对然后你提到的这个方式呢
其实我们不会用
对然后只是
可能
因为你刚才提到了那个MR可浮
那其实我们会会间接的来用它
但是不是直接来用
对这个我只能说到这了
对然后这个
因为MR可浮有它自己的这个
计算的这个
逻辑的这种诡局线性
对然后呢
这个标签的这个
数值的这个问题呢
其实比较好解决
因为这个我能大概给你解决一下
也就是说你的那个0.7的话
其实是因为有很多品种
坦率讲它是只适合做多的
是适合做多的
不适合做
对有的品种
是适合多空都做
有的品种只适合做多
对所有所有的像是这类的
呃这个
呃这个标定的
可能大概的我们建议就是做多
对就是只做多会会更容易一些
那特别像是这种像
呃QQQ啊
TQQ啊
就是像这类的
和美股这种相关的ETF的话
包括黄金啊等等
其实它
是适合只做多的
对那其实这点也也是
呃很很重要
对因为我如果不说的话
你可能就是一直是多空
呃同时去做训练
其实你把它换成只做多的话
可能效果会更好一些
然后我只
我只能讲到这了
希望你能理解
那
看看大家还有没有其他的
好的 谢谢老师
没事对
但是我觉得呃
我建议呃
因为我是觉得你可能做了
很多的这种工作哈
然后我是建议那个
你是可以尝试来这个认下
对其实因为我们这个
只是我们的一个
呃大家可能觉得比较难
但是对于我们来讲
其实这个只是一个入门的一个课程
因为后面我们还会有很多
更更自杂的这种
比它的这个课程
是在这个基础上的一个延续哈
那个我们其实都没有
对外都没有共产业减过
因为就是只有上过课的小伙伴才知道
对
ok
嗯
对大家可以在评论区打字
或者是可以上麦都没问题的
对然后呢
这会可能大家没说
我就中间插一嘴哈
因为其实五月份的这个
姨明老师的线架课
其实就是在上个周末
呃也才过去没几天
因为说实话
呃每一次来听完课后的小伙伴
包括今天我看到咱们这个这场
这个就是呃
大一会呢也看到有之前来听过课的
小伙伴也都在哈对
大家其实就感受会很
会很清晰
就是因为这两天的内容
看似是两天
但其实内容是非常的多的
而且顺便上可能据我所指吧
因为我本身也是在机构出来嘛
然后据我所指的话
目前国内是没有这样
像姨明老师
讲全站的这样的一个课程是没有的
因为对于国
因为我之前也一直是在国内嘛
所以说其实感受会比较深
尤其是在机构
因为没有哪个pm
会把他的全站的东西交给你的
在机构都是呃
每个qr呀qd呀
大家的职业能都非常的独立
因为站在机构老板的角度
他也不可能说
让下面的员工是都学会了
这个人家不自己吃派醋去单干了嘛
因为这个行业本身也都比较的现实
对所以说
包括今天我要请姨明老师做这个
打仪会呢
也都是因为之前有一些小伙伴
跟我有沟通过
那可能后续呢
因为我平时事也比较多
就没有跟着大家去聊具体
比如说哪还有一些疑问
所以我觉得最好的方式呢
可能就是把一些姨明老师请过来
然后呢
大家有什么问题
咱们就直接沟通
可能会更为直接一些
对
然后的话呢
就看看今天大家这个机会也比较难得
然后呢
就是大家有什么问题也都可以来问到
因为说实话
我们本身不是职业干卖课这件事的
因为也不靠这个生计哈
对
然后呢
就是我只能说是趁大家
如果是真的想后期往职业量化方向去走
就是趁着姨明老师
他他现在还有时间和精力
愿意想这个课
就真的是可以来听一听
因为如果后面他那天他不愿意讲了
就真的可能国内
你打着灯笼也不可能会有人愿意这样去讲
全占的东西了
这个放在机构的话说实话
就是pm他发产品的东西
对
所以就可能哪怕你去找一个小小机构
小思目的话
你问问你花多少钱
那pm他能愿意把他的策略交给你
也不现实
对
OK
我看到屏中去有问题
姨明老师麻烦您做一下解答吧
我看到了
然后是打完标签后进行布局训练
是怎样选样本
应该不是全部都运
对应项目行训练
这是这样的
训练的时候
当然说是在训练机上来做训练
但是正常情况下
我们是做样本外的样本外来做backtesting
就是来做这个测试
也就是说是样本内的测试机
其实我们都不会用
就是用完全跟它无关的布局
来做这个就是模型的这种评估
或者是做相应的这种处理
然后其实是样本外的样本
来扬个来讲的话
对
那第二个问题是
不所需要自己解释盘系统
一提话
这个不会的
这个实盘的代码
其实我们都给大家都写好了
懂
对
就是像这个第十个环节
就是实盘这个推理
实盘推理
因为很多时候
大家是训练完之后
其实在实盘的时候
它连不起来
因为这个实盘的这个还是满负杂的
谈出来讲
对
因为之前有那个很多小伙伴
就是他其实做的也很好
但是他就是在实盘的时候
他没有办法换起来
对
所以这边我们会把这个实盘
整个的这个推理的这个代码的逻辑
都和大家讲清楚
然后代码也是所有环节的
这是都是要给给那个
要给大家的
另外我看他提到
比如支持Tik级别的
自定义周作因子计划
Tik其实是可以的
但是其实是
你们如果你的交易频率比较高的话
其实是Tik级别是没有问题
但如果你交易频率
不是那么高的话
其实就没有没有没有
没有必要在Tik级别上做同产样
比如说你做这个
比如说股票
商品期货
甚至是股票
其实也都用不到Tik级的数据
那其实这个
如果是做这个
频率特别高的话
其实用Tik级别的数据
同产样才会有意义
就当说这个我们也都会讲
然后我再多说几句话
因为这个大家可能对这个
重产样比较
问题比较多
但是其实是这样的
因为我们要知道我们
同产样其实目的不是为了
把这个风度给的下降
让风度下降下来
对其实主要的目的不是为了这个
那这个是我们的附加的价值
主要其实我们追求的是
我们就配线也好
叫bar也好
就是每一个bar内部的
这个信息密度更均匀的一个问题
其实这个是最有意义的
并不是说我们表象上看到的这个
我们要把这个往下降
那其实这个我们怎么都能给它降下来
对那但是其实我们要知道我们目的是什么
因为它和我们后面的这个特征和标签
以及模型训练都是连着的
它不仅仅因为每一步它之间
它是有协同的
它不是完全独立的
你就像比如说我们在做
比如说我给大家举个例子
比如说我们在做这个
对在做截面
因为我们现在聊的更多的是持续
反映持续是低数
对然后持续地球打倒之后
然后我们再上截面
比如说那截面其实很多的这个因子
比如说一会儿有效
一会儿没效
其实问题出在不是在因子本身上
跟你的计算方式也无关
但其实基本上你的那个因子
其实是在这个轴上
是基于时间的
是基于时间维度
那也就是说我们做截面
比如说要做这个Alpha策略
对 它和这个Alpha
就是和你的这个
整个能获利的这个风格
其实是整个是有联系
那也就是说你本身基于的
这个Bassline其实是本身就没有统计意义
所以你用这个时间轴上的
基于实据一算的一些这个数学表达
然后你在做Alpha的时候
其实是有时有效
会有时没效
对 它不是说
那种简单的这种条件因子
你就能够或者是非线性
你直接上非线性
它就能找到这个规律
因为它你即使上了非线性
它其实也很难找到这个规律
所以我们无论是时续还是截面
那其实我们都希望
大家能够用这种重产样的这种方式
对 因为很多其实机构也在用
只是大家都对外公开吧
对 因为我们本身不做
我们和大家没有什么冲突
所以我才直接才愿意进行分享
包括后面的一些标签的标注方式等等
其实都是其实我们一直是我们的这种经验
对 有很多时候
其实不是说你一上来就知道了
有很多的细节和经验
其实是你在亏了很多的资金之后
慢慢的领悟出来的这个内容
对 OK
那看看大家还有没有什么问题
如果没问题的话
就可以先结束掉
Yuni 你这边
OK 就看看大家还有没有什么问题
对 然后我最后的话再跟大家补充一下
就是咱们的这个信价课程的内容
其实说白了
就是一套能够属然肯定能实盘
落地到实盘的一个基于存机器学习
机构起的这样的一个生产线
然后因为它是一个通用框架
不管说是像Crypto ATF商品期货股值
其实都可以直接复用
对 并且是基于数学逻辑的
然后所以说它的解释性更好
这个也是之前咱们很多来上过课的一些机构
小伙伴 谁的那个麦没关
对 可以关一下
对 因为国内说实话
因为我在这就不方便听名字了
就不少国内百亿级思目的QR
包括PM也都有来听过课
这个名字我就不便多说了
所以说这个作为机构是非常非常看重的一点
对 因为大家可能现在在平时听到的
可能都是一些比如说多因子相关
或是说是一些复性延报相关的
当然我不是说这个内容不好
当然其实包括我们之前在机构也有在用
但是其实这个仅仅只是整个Pipeline的
其中的一到两个环节
就是你把它做得再极致
也不可能说这会影响你这个策略
能够一定做得多好
就这个大家一定要清楚
就是量化它是一个系统
它不是说你只是做好一个环节
两个环节就能够做到很好的
就这点非常重要
OK 我看看评论区有问题
宏老师 麻烦您做一下解答吧
OK 看到了是
我看过我们所有的这个视频
二五年到现在过去一半
小伯众所有内容都是这样的
因为我们这个是方便给大家做这个演示
对 然后这个
因为现在很多商务客小伙伴
其实他们做的都很不错
也都拿到了很好的这个结果
因为他们有的时候会跟我说
有的时候会跟那个
跟Uni说的会更多
对 然后基本上都有很多拿到了结果
然后有的也都直接在机构的话
他们直接就发产品了
对 所以这个实盘是还是这个是和
就是直接就能够看到的
对 然后这是第一个问题
第二个问题就是
这个第二个问题是关于特征工程的
是复杂构造还是普通的这个
高低什么开盘收盘
是这样的 这个问题特征没有那么复杂
当然说也有比如说用更高阶的这个
数学表达来做
但是其实基本上比如说
开盘收盘最高最低其实这类的数据
其实已经勾我们来用了
对 那其实就是可以用这种方式来做
那比如说我们当时说
后面也会讲到很多的这种
比如说基于这个
拓谱的方式来处理这个课程的
包括还有一些
比如说像分数界来处理的
当然说其实也都是基于这个
开盘收盘然后这个最高价最低价
因为这个是我们的基础的这个
量价的这个数据
基本上是都就是无论你有上千
上万的特征
其实完全都是基于它来做计算的
对
还有一个小伙伴问
上课前应该准备哪些统计学的
知识有推荐的书籍
其实也不用太
我觉得只是对概率有初步的了解
就可以
因为Uni那边有那个现成的电子书
可以回来可以找一个Uni来要
对
有那个电子书可以可以发给大家来看一下
相应其实统计
统计其实还是蛮有意义的
然后在这个整个这个量化的这个
呃里面比如说像概率啊统计啊
还还有一些更深的内容
其实帮我们会理解这个
积极学习背后的这个逻辑啊
对
ok
嗯这个群的问题我来回答吧
这个咱们的话
对没有做这种就是什么交流群
因为我说实话
当然平时有很多小伙伴来加我问我
有什么交流群没有
我说实话没有
因为我觉得没必要
因为这个量化说实话
大家所谓的交流
就你哪怕你在一个公司
你同时时间都不带多聊两句的
你更何况你不认识的人呢
可能跟你多聊啥
那当然闲话当然可以聊
但是这二八斤的东西
大家不可能聊
如果说你想了解一下
课程的小金安排
这边都是我在安排
对
然后的话
你可以直接联系我就可以了
对
因为这种所谓的交流
我觉得片子也很多
这个就我也没法筛选
所以一直都没有那个
没有做这种什么所谓的交流群
当然咱们是每一期这个
有参课的小伙伴
我会去做一个这样
就是我们每期参课的小伙伴
会有一个群
因为这个大家都是
见过面是认识的
所以这个是有的
因为大家后续复线过程当中
还有很多问题
也都可以在群里沟通
或是直接联系到英明老师
这个都没问题的
因为上课
其实包括每次我们上课
到最后英明老师都会说
上课不是终点
因为你上完课
课后完之后
我们还有一个复线的过程
那复线过程当中
还有很多的细节问题
这个是每个人的问题会不一样
所以后续的话呢
咱们的这个课后有问题
都可以直接问到英明老师
因为自己如果说去琢磨的话
可能一个问题就得卡几个月
这中间的时间成本
和经历成本太高了
对
然后大致的情况就是这样子
然后看看大家还没有其他的问题
对
哦
有问怎么联系到
然后这是
现在屏幕上显示的是
Uni的那个微信
我简单介绍一下Uni
因为Uni是
呃
就是我之前那个美国的
一个同志的学生
对
然后Uni本身在国内
其实他
其实他比较低调哈
因为他之前是在一家百亿字幕做
对
然后他是这个
但是说现在已经过来了哈
对
然后这个
呃
其实他大家有很多问题
可以直接问他
其实他
本身也很厉害
Uni
英明老师
我看到评论区还有一个问题
对
你可以解答一下
那是成交额的肘
对
那是成交
那是成交额的肘
对
介绍
原理
原理其实就是我们用
呃
比如说你达到多
达到多少的这个预值
然后我们来生产我们的这个
呃
这个
生产我们的开线啊
对
其实原理比较简单
OK
那大家有什么
再有什么问题
就可以这个联系Uni啊
对
他会帮大家
大家直接对接
对
大家如果后续有相关课程的问题
都可以联系我
然后英明老师目前在国内的这个课程
也就也都只有我这边在安排
就其他可能会有一些人说相关的
基本上就都是骗子
就也不希望大家上当受骗
对
所以大家有相关的问题联系我就可以了
然后呢
看看今天大家如果没有问题的话呢
我们就先暂时到这里了
好吧
然后后续的话呢
就大家就咱们随时沟通
好吧
OK
感谢英明老师今天特地抽时间出来
给咱们做这样的一个答疑
然后呢
小伙伴们
大家也都希望大家
不管是听客与否话的
也都希望大家之后的这个交易出路
都越来越好
好吧
然后呢
咱们今天就先到这里了
然后再见
谢谢大家
再见
拜拜